♪♪♪
- [Adam Lefkoe:] All right,
so this is the challenge.
Keenan is guarding Casey.
- [Casey Hayward:] He needs help.
He needs help.
Oh, I countered him! I countered him!
Hey, I countered him.
- What happened that time, Keenan?
- You see, that was some of my shit.
He's stealing my shit now.
♪♪♪
- What up, everybody? Lefkoe here.
And it is time for "Underrated,"
sponsored by State Farm,
an incredible company with
surprisingly great rates.
Just like this show is hopefully home
to some surprisingly great Madden ratings.
And our guest today is the
surprisingly great Casey Hayward.
But I'm unsurprisingly
annoyed at his Madden ratings.
Let's get a ratings adjuster on the line.
Hey, Jake, call Madden.
Let's do this.
- [Jake:] Calling Madden Ratings Adjuster.
- [Lefkoe:] Look at that
hat, look at that face.
Clint Oldenburg.
What a legend.
Good to see you, pal.
- Hey, Adam, how you doin'?
- This whole Chargers team,
I think, is underrated.
I got Casey Hayward,
cornerback, good friend of mine.
We went to kindergarten together.
He's good at defending wide receivers.
What about wide receiver traits?
What about release?
Can we bump that up?
- You're always throwing
these curveballs at us, man.
I don't know why.
Is he planning on maybe
running a franchise
where he switches his position
to receiver or something?
- That's not something
you need to worry about.
I just asked you a yes-or-no question.
Can we improve it?
- Maybe. We'd have to see,
you know, we have to see evidence.
- You're about to.
Hey, Jake, call Casey Hayward
- [Jake:] Calling Casey Hayward.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] There he is,
my guy Casey Hayward.
This is Clint Oldenburg.
- Man, how you doin'?
- Look, I'm gonna jump right into it, OK?
Putting all your ratings up on the screen,
time to go to work.
If you see what I see,
I'm looking at 90s across the board
in nearly all of your core skills.
You gotta be feeling that.
- I agree with that.
They got, they got all those.
My change of direction,
my route recognition.
That's all up there to par.
- And yet, your overall
does not reflect that.
I'm like, "What could be
holding this man back?"
And to me, I think it's your speed at 89.
- It's probably my speed.
Even though it's at 89, you know.
I don't really get ran by that much.
I don't get ran by that much.
- [Adam:] Clint, speed.
I wanna almost race him
against his own character.
What do we think?
- Whew, I would love to see that actually.
But our speed rating is literally,
"What is the top-end speed
of each individual player?"
- This can go up, this can go down, right?
- Yes. Absolutely.
With speed, it can be very fluid.
- [Lefkoe:] OK. I'm gonna
get you this footage.
We're gonna turn that
fluidity into a solid.
Not sure what that means,
but you got footage coming your way.
- All right. We'll be
on the lookout for it.
♪♪♪
- [Lefkoe:] Casey versus Madden Casey,
20 yards, and I am ready.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
From my perspective, man,
you were looking blazing fast.
How did it feel?
- I hope so. I'm tired.
- [Lefkoe:] How many
times a game do you do
a 20-yard all-out sprint?
- For me, maybe, like,
40 percent of the game.
- All right, man. Whenever you're ready,
we're gonna need you to do it again, OK?
- I got one more?
OK.
♪♪♪
- Let's make this the one, Casey.
On my mark.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
- Let's hope that was faster than my guy.
- It's a tough call.
So, Casey, I was saying earlier,
when we were looking at your DB skills,
all of your core skills are
still rated really high.
So I went through the rest of
your ratings, and I thought,
why not give your overall a boost
by going after one of your lower ratings?
And I picked release.
And I knew we were gonna
need some help with that.
So...
- [Keenan Allen:] Hey, Showcase.
How you feel about doing some
release drills, something,
cuz I feel like my press
DB skills is still like
that from high school.
You know, I was the No. 1 guy.
So I really feel like I can
get after you a little bit.
- All right. So this is the challenge.
Are we accepting?
- [Together:] Let's do it.
- Man, I was hoping you'd say that.
Cuz I took the liberty of
mocking up an epic battle
in Madden where Keenan is guarding Casey,
and this is what we got.
Take a look.
- Oh, my God.
You said he got a 12 release?
And he's sliding on me.
- Ooh, he got you there, man.
- Nice speed.
- [Lefkoe:] No. 2.
- It's one-on-one.
Oh, my God.
- I routed him. I routed him.
- Now that you know the drill,
Casey, you're gonna get five snaps
and five yards to shake Keenan.
- All right.
- But your shit might
go down if I kill you.
- My press?
- Yes.
- What's my press?
- [Lefkoe:] Keenan, it doesn't matter.
I'm sorry, this episode,
it is all about Casey.
- Let's do it.
♪♪♪
- I don't even know how
to do it. Is this it?
- Nah. Hell nah.
- That ain't it? OK.
I gotta go down here.
- Look at that.
- Oh, man. Shit.
[Buzzer]
- That's 1-nothing Keenan.
[Ding]
- [Casey:] OK, get him on his heels!
Get him on his heels.
1-1.
- What happened that time, Keenan?
- I tried to do the Pat
P. shit, lil' quick,
it didn't work.
It didn't work.
- All right. Third battle.
Let's get it going.
- Ahh!
[Buzzer]
- Dang!
Damn!
- [Lefkoe:] And the high school
All-American holds strong in Round No. 3.
- That's 2-1.
[Ding]
- [Lefkoe:] And Casey just
barely edges Keenan out.
- Let's go! Let's go.
Let's go.
- You see, that was some of my shit.
He's stealing my shit now.
- All right, Casey. So it is 2-2.
- Yeah.
- What is the move that you're thinking
will get him to bite?
- I might go back with the
same move I just got him.
He's not gonna think I'mma do it again.
- [Lefkoe:] So he doesn't
think you're gonna go scissors
twice in a row?
- Now we thinkin'.
- [Lefkoe:] OK. It sounds solid.
- You're goin' there.
- He need help.
He need help.
[Ding]
- [Casey:] Oh, I countered him!
I countered him!
Hey, I countered him!
- That's what I'm talking about, Casey.
These ratings are flying up.
- I was 12.
I gotta go up.
- [Lefkoe:] Keenan, man.
Big ups to you, dude.
Coming out, helping us today.
- Appreciate it, man.
Get my boy right.
Get him right.
- [Lefkoe:] All right, Casey.
You put some great stuff on film today.
We're gonna get these ratings up,
Casey. I promise.
♪♪♪
Clint, I told you. He put it on film.
Give me the breakdown.
What do we think?
- Hey, I was really happy
to watch Casey on film.
You know, it's always nice
to get up close and personal
with some of these guys and
get some more information.
Just wanna call out one of the ratings
that he really cares about the most
is one of the hardest
in Madden to improve.
- Lotta people argue with
you guys about speed, huh?
- Yes. Speed is the one that
players care about the most.
- Let's get Casey Hayward
on the phone right now.
- Yo, yo, yo, yo.
What's goin' on?
- Casey, man I have next to me
is the ultimate Madden plug.
He is the ratings adjuster.
- What's up, Clint, man?
- Casey, welcome. Really
appreciate you taking the time
to put yourself on film
for us to do some further evaluation.
- Oh, for sure, man.
I appreciate it.
I know, I know that speed is
the hardest one to adjust.
I'm glad I was able to
put a little bit on film.
I didn't give my all on the run.
I hope it didn't drop.
That's all that matters.
- Really what we noticed was
Casey seemed like he was
unable to really go full speed,
and likely that's because
he's got an NFL schedule
to worry about.
So based on what we watched,
that speed rating's not
gonna change at all.
- I'm OK with that.
I'm OK with that.
I'm OK with that because
I wasn't even fresh.
- You don't wanna push it too hard.
We understand that.
We're not gonna dock you.
- Clint, now let's take us to release
because I know that what he was
doing on Keenan was special.
- Yeah. Actually we were,
we were pretty impressed
with the release stuff.
You know, really impressed.
Even though, you know,
only won three out of five,
he's actually gonna go up 25 points
in the release rating because-
[Casey laughing]
- That's where I needed
my points to go up,
not my speed.
I'm OK with that.
Give me my release stuff.
- Clint, I have to ask you now:
Was Casey Hayward underrated?
- Casey Hayward was underrated
on the offensive side of the ball.
Other than that, I think we
got him pretty good here.
- And there is Clint.
The only thing he defends
better than Casey Hayward
on passes is his ratings.
We'll take it, though.
We're gonna take it.
- I'mma take it.
- And there you have it
from State Farm's surprisingly great rates
to Casey Hayward's
surprisingly great ratings.
Thank you for checking out "Underrated."
♪♪♪